well i mean they're making it kind of
easy on us
if they're really going to pursue this
you know
push to get rid of the electoral college
if they're really going to try to pack
the courts
if joe biden's not going to stand up and
stop the impeachment
then yeah i mean it does make our job
easy if they pursue these radical
policies
that most of america outside of you know
major metropolitan areas
don't support it is going to make our
job easier
when trump over the last couple months
especially right before the election was
was shining a lot of light on you guys
and
telling people you know watch newsmax
fox in the morning is crazy
watch newsmax they're doing good stuff
and then he'll point people to oan and
then the next day he hates this network
and suddenly he likes these guys
uh how sort of aware is everybody that
like oh
trump's watching now and we better
i don't know act accordingly ignore it
what oh i
everyone's very aware obviously and you
know you know sometimes
it's it's just kind of strange knowing
that they have uh
us on at the white house and that you
know again something you say might
actually matter
inside that building and that again
there are times i just
can't believe that's actually the case
now that said
you know we do try to make sure that we
do not become trump tv that's not the
objective here
at newsmax um you know the former mayor
of new york city ed koch had that saying
that you know if you agree with me 80
of the time great you know if you agree
with me 100 percent of the time you need
to get your head checked out
and you know no politician is right 100
of the time
and as i tell people and i try you know
encourage my staff as much as you may
love donald trump and i'm have to be
reminded of this himself because
myself because i you know really did
think the trump presidency
could be transformational um and
consequential and it has been
um and it you know it's disappointing
that there will not be another four
years because you think about all the
good things that happened
what could have been continued but again
you know you just have to really tell
people that once somebody once you
bubble in that bubble and choose
somebody
to represent you in elected office
they're not your friend anymore
it's not your sports team you don't
support them like that you got to hold
them accountable
and we can compliment the things that
donald trump does right
and we can criticize the things that he
does wrong
you know it's the only way you can
really honestly consider yourself
you know a check on the powerful and if
you don't do it
eventually for somebody like donald
trump or be honest with his supporters
you don't really have
the moral authority or the credibility
to do it to joe biden and we've seen
that you know with other
people you have to find some place you
can agree with the opposition
but also disagree with your own side
in a weird way do you think that that'll
make your job a little bit easier
having a biden administration because
people will know
okay you didn't want biden but now you
can like sort of be more
openly critical like i gotcha you
weren't pulling punches but that it
that in a weird way conservatives are
almost set up to be
to be the against team you know i mean
they're making it kind of easy on us if
they're really going to pursue
this you know push to get rid of the
electoral college if they're really
going to try to pack the courts
if joe biden's not going to stand up and
stop the impeachment
then yeah i mean it does make our job
easy if they pursue these radical
policies
that most of america outside of you know
major metropolitan areas
don't support it is going to make our
job easier if they continue to call for
defunding the police
and we watch once great cities like los
angeles and philadelphia and new york
and portland oregon and atlanta continue
to decline and you know become places of
decay
it's going to make our jobs easier and
i'm not hopeful for that i definitely
want to see the best for america
but if they continue to pursue these
policies if they do what they tell us
they were going to do
during the campaign then i'm sad to say
that our jobs will be much easier
yeah god and as i said before i hate to
tell you
i think they're gonna do it yeah i i
just my take is just that they're gonna
do it that they're
they're enough there's just nothing too
crazy which is a very weird
a very weird thing i and again this is
where i come back to the american people
they're not going to let them do it i
hope i was i was reading about this
today well what if what if big tech just
stops the american people from letting
them connect
we can't that's the next one i go on
your show and talk about this a lot
yeah you know the thing is is we existed
without big tech and i don't want to
diminish
the risk that this poses um and you know
you hear about things like
um email providers cracking down on
donald trump's ability to reach his
supporters through email
and and radio networks telling you know
their radio host and i
just yesterday i was saying look they're
coming for us on big tech but there may
there may still be those other
avenues where conservatives used to
reach their audiences and i am concerned
about that
but i do have faith in the american
public in bartow county georgia today i
was reading about
local elections officials there and the
county commissioners there
and they're doing a recount a hand
recount of all the ballots there
from the georgia senate runoffs not that
they need to it didn't qualify
you know the race was not within the
margin that they require the recount
but what they're doing is they're using
this as an opportunity to build
confidence and show the people who want
to participate that it was a legitimate
process
complete transparency and they're also
using it to train people
how to be poll watchers and how to
process the ballots next time around
so you know i gave that long monologue
last week when you were on my show
about the real fight is at the local
level
getting involved people rolling up their
sleeves going to the school board going
to the county commission becoming poll
watchers becoming poll workers
and you know i'm so encouraged to seeing
that happening and
again you have 1.5 million people that
can be
really mad if something happens to your
show
and you know we got to pick our battles
to make sure they can't do this to us
we got to hold our lawmakers accountable
because they pass these laws that
they're not willing to enforce
you know if they're not going to do that
get those laws off the books president
trump was right for trying to repeal
section 230.
you know it's a law from 1996 dave and
can you imagine
trying to use a computer from 1996 in
today's technological world
they need to get rid of this law it's
it's expired
are you saying my apple 2c i guess that
was that was probably 1986
did you have pork the game quark what
was it that was
quark oh no i'm thinking hubert is the
guy jumping on the that i know cubert
who's cork
cork was some game on my apple 2e i
think and there was winter olympics too
i loved that game do you
winter olympics wasn't oh i i definitely
remember winter olympics i had that on
nintendo but
what about lemonade stand did you have
that stand was a great and speaking of
the winter olympics in the 80s since how
great
were the winter olympics in the 80s when
you had the eastern bloc
and you like you know if you did if the
if the united states did not beat
the eastern bloc and whether it was
downhill skiing or any sport it was like
oh what does it say about us as a nation
you know i will tell you this i've said
this on my show a couple times i think
that
like if you think of rocky iv you know
against drago right he's fighting drago
in moscow
on christmas day we knew as americans
who our enemy was right it was russia
was the enemy now now that's you don't
want to live in a perfectly polarized
world but i think it
that thing where we were fighting the
russian empire we were america for
capitalism
they were for communism it was like that
was the thing
and it sort of helped define ourselves i
actually think that one of the reasons
we're so out of whack right now is we
don't know who our enemy is we don't
know if it's external or internal
we don't know if the good guys or the
good guys or the bad guys are bad guys
did russia affect our election or hate
trump or help trump is
trying to like none of it makes sense so
people
often define themselves by what they're
against and we don't know what we're
against right now i know and you think
about
that movie you think about uh red dawn
or you think about
there was this movie called ruski's
remember that one about a uh
you know all the people that used to
defect and this is another thing about
you know sports is
you know people from cuba or russia or
eastern european countries that used to
defect
to the united states because we all
believed this was the best place
for freedom and now it feels like only
half of this country believes
that this is a place you should actually
defect to if you're an athlete
but if you're you know an immigrant they
want to open up the door and let
everybody in and it's just
so strange to hear that it's a little
odd that nobody
leaves america although i think that may
be changing kind of soon right i mean if
it was
if it was as bad for all of these years
as they'd said you'd think somebody
would leave the only people who leave
are the are the rich guys who put the
money in the cayman islands and
disappear to the galapagos islands
that's right they they've got some place
else to go and you know
the people i love this list of people
i'm leaving
if donald trump wins of course they
never left i you know love it or leave
it really is it and it you know this is
where
i wish more americans you know actually
would travel around the world
and appreciate how great it is to live
in this country still to this day
how much better we have it than anywhere
else i mean you know
we talk about big tech cramping down on
us and you know i was just really
repulsed to see a chinese communist
newspaper
saying oh look look what's happening in
america it's dangerous to crack down on
free speech i mean
they're signaling to their population
that america
the idea of america and freedom and
liberty you know life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness isn't real
and the fact that that doesn't get more
coverage or you don't have a universal
response
uh from this country in fact you have
some news outlets actually unwillingly
you know not unwillingly but unknowingly
taking money from the chinese communist
party and
you know propagating their propaganda uh
without knowing it
you know you would think to your point
that there would be more awareness about
how dangerous
the enemy is and that's china if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell